the images are no less shocking even
with the passing of time
new videos now emerged of the chaos and
the violence
the mob turning on police and spraying
them with mace
this officer was trapped pinned by a
metal door
and screaming for help that didn't come
anger at donald trump accused of
inciting this is growing all the time
twitter his megaphone of choice has
permanently suspended his accounts a
move which is causing
even greater divisions the problem
you've got now is that by
banning him you've separated the you
know divisive in america is always at an
all-time high already
they've now separated the two sides all
of these people now are going into this
echo chamber of parlor
where conspiracy theories are running
crazy um and it's just going to get
worse they're adding fuel to the fire
law enforcement is still playing
catch-up appealing for help from the
public to
identify the perpetrators some were not
hard to find
many of the most notorious alleged
defenders have already been arrested
and charged the flag here is flying at
half-mast
in memory of the police officer brian
siknik who was killed during the
violence
you can see security has been tightened
up massively a fence has been erected
around the perimeter
and the national guard's been drafted in
but the immediate question for homeland
security is how did this happen in the
first place
and how do you stop it happening again
with the inauguration of president-elect
joe biden
less than two weeks away america's
political horror show
is also set for another act impeachment
proceedings against trump may go before
the house next week
speaker nancy pelosi is promising
decisive action
but as the transfer of power nears and
with only a few days left in trump's
term
impeaching him for a second time another
first for the norm breaking president
risks even greater disunity those people
who were storming the capital
and who are now in danger of being
arrested and prosecuted
those people would feel like martyrs and
they would think that
donald trump was a martyr particularly
if
this impeachment is only a democratic
effort
the fallout from the capitol building
insurrection
will throw a dystopian shadow over
american politics for a long time to
come
the madness and the mayhem of the trump
term
will soon be over but the demented
tribalism he engendered and fostered
will be much harder to move past